[Musique]
nous sommes le 29 mai bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 les
invités aujourd'hui en plateau jury
reste garcia yvelinoise de 21 ans elle
est l'une des ambassadrices de
l'association one a lancé par le
chanteur bono du hope you to
l'association qui s'engage dans la
campagne des législatives et qui
souhaite que les candidats prennent des
positions claires nettes en faveur de
l'afrique
gwenola firmin conservatrice au château
de versailles reviendra sur l'exposition
consacrée à pierre legrand le monarque
russe est à l'honneur dans la cité
royale est aujourd'hui la place dîmière
poutine était d'ailleurs sur place et
puis elle nous irons aussi à la
rencontre est un acteur cet acteur c'est
chris rankin alias percy weasley vous
l'avez peut-être reconnu dans la saga
harry potter il est venu rencontrer ses
fans ce week-end
on débute donc avec vous bonsoir julia
et reste garcia 21 ans vous êtes un
clayes-sous-bois ambassadrice
pour roanne une ong
cofondée par bono le leader du groupe
yachts ou et qui s'engage contre
l'extrême pauvreté et notamment en
afrique une ong qui revendique plus de
385 milles et membres en france millions
de soutien à travers le monde ce qui
vous a séduit c'est la forme
d'engagement plutôt une forme
d'engagement plutôt inédite
ça fait assez longtemps que shanghai
associativement mais c'est vrai que
wayne ou rennes offrez vraiment une
manière inédite de s'engager a vraiment
influencé à l'aider sur poétique d'une
manière enfin voilà inédite pour des
jeunes comme nous et autrement que par
le monde le don s'engager vraiment sur
les causes structurelles en fait comment
owen intervient justement concrètement
sur le terrain
alors il ya différents égards on fait
trois pôles principaux de chez valmet
donc tout d'abord il ya le celui de la
mobilisation citoyenne est ce pas là le
but c'est vraiment de sensibiliser les
citoyens aux causes qui sont défendues
par orange est donc principalement la
lutte contre l'extrême pauvreté en
afrique est aussi le deuxième point qui
est vraiment important c'est celui de
leurs finances et des décideurs
politiques
et justement à travers également cette
mobilisation citoyenne plus on est
nombreux plus on l'a l'influencé me
c'est également par les médias j'ai eu
des réalisations concrètes il ya une
campagne en faveur de l'augmentation du
budget d'être publique au développement
il
et encore je cite quelques opérations
que j'ai noté et d assurer aussi le
financement à plus de 37 milliards de
dollars d'initiatives en matière de
santé comme le fonds mondial de lutte
contre le sida
voilà quelques-unes des réalisations où
vous êtes ambassadrice depuis quand et
en quoi ça consiste sur le terrain
depuis février donc c'est assez récent
pas tombé une cinquantaine de jeunes sur
la france répartis dans les différentes
régions en fonction en fait deux ont
étudié ou en vie et en fait c'est à la
fois du local c'est-à-dire sensibiliser
les personnes dans notre entourage dans
nos établissements scolaires dans nos
villes et aussi comme je voulais des
études quai en rencontrant les décideurs
nos décideurs locaux et donc là dans le
cas des initiatives c'est ce qu'on va
faire justement rencontré les députés
dans le no circonscription pour les
influencer comment on devient
ambassadrice des quads et un casting
auparavant alors oui c'est vrai ça me
rend dingue astier
donc on peut suivre sur internet tout
simplement ça se fait dans les environs
du mois de décembre avec un cv voilà un
petit questionnaire répond pour montrer
son engagement et voilà alors cet
engagement ça s'appelle l'opération cap
ou pas cap auprès des candidats à cette
élection législative
vous leur demandez quoi est ce que
certains ont déjà répondu aux appels de
rencontre alors j'ai certains de mes
camarades ambassadeurs qui ont eu des
réponses donc c'est plutôt positif on
est au tout début donc voila mais on a
on avale a tout le temps à grosses
gouttes alors oui mais ça s'arrête pas
aux gens ça c'est important de le dire
tout le long et quand toulon en fait des
cinq ans pendant lesquels les personnes
les députés sur moi et lui on sera là
pour le rappeler les engagements et des
enjeux qui joue demain en permanence en
fait donc c'est pas que maintenant c'est
aussi surtout long de l'année et donc
les principales demandes c'est que ces
députés soient actifs pour permettre
l'augmentation temps voulu des 0,7 pour
cent à voir 0 2 7% compte du rnb dont du
revenu national brut consacrés à l'aide
publique au développement c'est un
engagement qui ont un engagement qui
date de 50 ans qui n'a toujours pas été
pris et aussi que cette aide soit plus
centrée sur les pays les plus
vulnérables et les plus pauvres
notamment d'afrique est aussi que l'aide
soit centrée sur les femmes et les
filles les populations les plus
vénérables en somme est ce qu'on aura un
suivi de ces engagements qui peuvent
être pris parce que j'imagine que les
candidats sont plutôt enclins à venir
vous rencontrer à échanger à dire mais
bien sûr on s'engagera mais ensuite vous
allez suivre noté évolué tout ça sera sa
trace et justement elle a cessé le
travail de l'année
et aussi de nous en tant qu'ambassadeur
de continuer à interpeller les candidats
qui se sont engagés tout au long de leur
mandat vraiment leur dire vous êtes
engagés sur ça nous on attend vraiment
les engagements notamment dans le cadre
du vote de la loi du projet de loi
finances au moins deux à l'automne ça
est très important de voter le vote du
budget dans le cadre de l'aide publique
au développement et blanc soit là pour
le rappeler leurs engagements
il y avait déjà eu ce genre d'opérations
pendant l'élection présidentielle la
plusieurs candidats dont président élu
avait répondu favorablement s'était
engagé là aussi vous allez scruter ce
que ce que fera dans les prochains mois
prochaines années matouba dès qu'un
événement qsssl baala dans le cadre du
g7 où que ce soit dans le cadre du g20
dans le cadre de l'union européenne
aussi on sera là pour rappeler les
engagements de chamakh personnellement
vous allez poursuivre cet engagement au
delà de cette campagne de façon je suis
jeune norma service toute l'année
après moi c'est quelque chose qui me
tient à coeur donc oui je j'ai à coeur
de mobiliser mes amis autour de moi que
ce soit à travers les pétitions à
travers tout un ensemble de choses
trouve que c'est important en tant que
citoyen ça me tient à coeur donc oui
pour voir un petit peu qu'on comprenne
pour ceux qui voudraient peut-être vous
vous rejoindrez vous aider dans cette
opération là sur le terrain concrètement
vous aller les rencontrer on vous en
voyez juste des questionnaires vous les
interpellés parce que les engagements ne
crois finalement que voilà qui croient
et au final derrière comment tout ça va
comment tout ça sur le terrain vous
allez pouvoir voir des engagements
clairs pour vous donner un exemple un
peu concret ce soir au quai sont bas il
ya un débat public hyper justement sur
les questions de solidarité
internationale donc il y aura trois des
principaux candidats de la 12e
circonscription des yvelines
et donc voilà c'est vraiment les
rencontrer et si on ne sait pas comment
voyez ce n'est pas que envoyé des
questionnaires ou des miles est vraiment
allé à leur rencontre discuter avec eux
et voilà faire le suivi des engagements
ça c'est le plus important
mais tout ça vous sert dans vos études
aussi peut-être oui être plus à l'aise
en toutes allées chaudes entre les
candidats en carrière en politique
peut-être alors est ce que ça vous
intéresse moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
surtout l'associatif mais oui ça aide
bien sûr merci beaucoup je dis ars
carbassas driss one donc en france et
notamment sur les yvelines cet
engagement pour demander aux candidats
aux élections législatives de s'engager
pour l'afrique vous pouvez retrouver
tous les détails sur le site internet de
luigi qui s'est affichée merci encore à
venir
nous poursuivrons ce set 8 invités avec
de la culture à présent le château de
versailles propose à partir de
demain le 30 mai est sa nouvelle
exposition pierre legrand un sahara en
france cent cinquante cinq oeuvres qui
retracent la visite en france du
monarque russe en 1717 il fut logé une
dizaine de jours au grand trianon
l'exposition est intégré à la première
rencontre entre le président de la
république emmanuel macron et son
homologue russe vladimir poutine s'était
ce lundi après midi à versailles michael
et demi d'euros a rencontré gwenola
firmin c'est la conservatrice du château
de versailles et du trianon est ce que
vous nous présenter cette exposition
alors cette exposition commémore le
tricentenaire de la visite du tsar
pierre le grand en france il arrive en
france le 21 avril 1717 et il s'en va à
la fin du mois de juin 1717
elle a lieu au château de versailles et
en particulier au grand trianon puisque
le tsar va séjourner à deux reprises au
grand trianon à la fois à la fin du mois
de mai au début du mois d'août alors
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve dans cette
exposition on retrouve beaucoup d'objets
du tsar puisque
elle est issue d'un partenariat
exceptionnel entre le château de
versailles et le musée de l'ermitage
le musée de l'ermitage conserve
aujourd'hui la collection d objets ayant
appartenu à pierre le grand est
donc nous avons eu la chance d'avoir
cent cinq oeuvres prêtées par l'héritage
et parmi ses oeuvres on retrouve des
objets uniques que l'on retrouve des
objets uniques vous avez par exemple le
costume d'été que pierre legrand portait
lors de cette visite protocolaire
donc nous les exposons ainsi que son
nécessaire de voyage comme par exemple
un coffre à pharmacie ou une cassette
personnelle du tsar c'est une exposition
qui a demandé beaucoup de temps au
niveau de la préparation
c'est une exposition que nous avons
préparé relativement rapidement mais
nous avons travaillé d'arrache-pied
puisqu'elle représente 155 oeuvre mais
elle est le sujet resserré puisque il
traite vraiment de cette visite en
france
donc après une grande présentation du
tsar et de son premier voyage en europe
qui a lieu à la fin du xviie siècle
nous sommes vraiment au coeur du sujet
et nous voyons les relations que le sar
va entretenir avec celle france qu'il va
visiter en particulier paris et surtout
versailles et les demeures qui
l'entourent comme par exemple marly où
saint cyr et pourquoi avoir décidé de
l'installer ici au trianon
alors elle a lieu ici au trianon tout
simplement parce que pierre legrand a
dormi par deux fois à trianon sous bois
et
elle a lieu exactement dans les lieux
qui ont été parcourus par le tsar et sa
suite pour mais quand même temps pour la
visiter cette exposition
alors on est combien de temps tout
dépend bien sûr toutes les personnes qui
la visitent
je dirais que il ya énormément d'objets
qui mérite beaucoup d'attention il ya
toutes les techniques à la fois des arts
graphiques des peintures il ya des
sculptures extraordinaire notamment un
portrait du tsar pas rastrelli qui est
un véritable chef-d'oeuvre
on a une grande tapisserie qui constitue
également un cadeau diplomatique de la
france au tsar à l'époque il ya des
livres il ya des instruments de médecine
il ya des instruments scientifiques
issus des collections de pierre le grand
et c'est vrai qu'on peut passer beaucoup
de temps sur l'ensemble de ses
collections
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que les
visiteurs retiennent de cette exposition
j'aimerais qu'ils retiennent que pierre
le grand a été le grand réformateur de
la russie celui qui a fait entrer la
russie dans la modernité
c'était à la fois un grand conquérant
c'était aussi un esprit animé d'une
curiosité universel et venant en france
il a souhaité justement assouvir cette
curiosité universel et en achetant des
objets en allant vers les artistes en
ont en en attirant certains en russie
notamment
et on se faisant prendre lui-même
notamment par nattier même si nati ne va
pas ne va pas en russie
c'était un amateur d'art est un amateur
d'art français nous restons à versailles
mais nous changeons d'univers rencontre
à présent avec chris rankin sept acteurs
d'harry potter joue le rôle de percy
weasley dans la saga donc harry potter
le grand frère de ron s'est rendu dans
la cité royale pour échanger avec
quelques fans du film propos recueillis
par nicolas landry why did you que c'est
pourquoi avez vous accepté de venir
aujourd'hui
mais qu'est-ce que je ne suis jamais
venu à versailles avant ce qui est
toujours une bonne raison de venir
quelque part si on n'y est jamais allé
tout cela est très sympathique il n'y a
rien de plus excitant que de venir dans
un magasin dédié à harry potter et
rencontrer des fans d'harry potter est
toujours un plaisir
il n'y a rien de plus excitant qu'est ce
que vous ressentez quand vous voyez
beaucoup de fans autour de l'agneau est
assez formidable c'est toujours étrange
je fais ça depuis assez longtemps ça
fait presque 17 ans 16 ans et demi que
le premier film est sorti je pense
toujours que cet étrange les gens ne
viennent pas me rencontrer moi mais ils
viennent rencontrer part si ce n'est des
harry potter c'est important c'est
toujours étrange mais aussi très
touchant harry potter signifie beaucoup
de choses pour les gens c'était toute
leur enfance c'est incroyable de faire
partie de ça c'est agréable de voir les
gens venir pour dire ça et dire merci
venir nous rencontrer
qu'est ce que vous pensez de versailles
peut-être que le château de versailles
c'est comme un poudlard non oui c'est
comme une autre version de poudlard
poudlard est très différent du château
de versailles
je pense qu'il est plus grandiose je ne
vais pas encore vu je l' ai aperçu quand
on m'a conduit ici mais je vais
peut-être aller l'explorer le succès est
dédié entièrement harry potter j'ai déjà
fait des choses en dehors mais rien
d'aussi énorme
maintenant je travaille derrière la
scène en faisant des programmes de
télévision en travaillant pour des
productions de télévision donc je ne
suis plus devant la caméra il fallait
quand même on a faim mais je pense je ne
sais pas harry potter c'est vraiment
quelque chose de spécial je n'ai pas
besoin de continuer n'importe où
qu'il est votre meilleur souvenir oxman
et il y en a tellement 17 ans de tous à
toutes les choses lors de ma première
rencontre avec jk rowling
la première fois que j'ai découvert le
studio la séquence avec la famille
weasley dans la gare de king's cross la
première fois qu'on a marché dans l'os
vraiment tout tous les jours il y avait
quelque chose de nouveau quelque chose
de différent et des choses parfois même
complètement ridicule et c'était génial
faire tous ces films
c'était juste fou
c'est la fin du set 8 invités pour ce
soir les replays sur notre site internet
excellente soirée
[Musique]